so welcome to the February PI data
meetup in Arbor
to start I just want to acknowledge our
sponsors some numbness which sponsors
meetup TD Ameritrade for this beautiful
space and Midas who provided the food so
some points so emergency exits are both
back the way you came and over here you
can provide feedback to any of the
meeting organizers myself ROS Shawn and
Ben we also have a github which you can
find here in addition to Twitter and
Gmail you can provide feedback there as
well we are in a borrow two space so
please clean up after yourself a couple
of notes on QA so unless quick hold
questions until the end please phrase
your question in the form of a question
try to keep questions to 30 seconds or
less avoid long statements or monologues
and a reminder that there will be time
for open discussion after the Q&A so I'm
gonna read our PI data Code of Conduct
PI data is dedicated to providing a
harassment free meaning experience for
everyone regardless of gender sexual
orientation gender identity and
expression disability physical
appearance body size race religion or
experience we do not tolerate harassment
of meaning participants in any form all
communication should be appropriate for
a professional audience including people
of many different backgrounds and levels
of experience sexual language and
imagery is not appropriate for any of
our meet-up events be kind to others do
not insult or put-down other attendees
behave professionally remember that
harassment and sexist racist or
exclusionary jokes are not appropriate
for pi data attendees violating these
rules may be asked to leave the meetup
at the sole discretion of the meetup
organizers thank you for helping make
this a welcoming friendly event for all
so we're gonna do a quick icebreaker
provided to us by Amy so turn to someone
next to you that you don't already know
introduce yourself and we'll talk for a
little bit about which do you think is
more likely UFOs or Bigfoot so this
month in data science so I read a little
bit about this has a homework for this
but there is an interesting discussion
form here so there's a pet finder at my
kaggle contest and the first-place
winner was disqualified so there's an
interesting conversation about sort of
the ethics of data science and how we as
a community can be working together in
order to sort of further especially this
cause was for you know helping determine
how how long it takes animals to be
adopted out of a shelter right so for a
you know a great cause and folks sort of
took it and did some bad stuff so very
interesting read a great instance of the
community coming together and also
people ultimately you know being honest
and they returned the money that's good
all right so our yeah our next event so
our March meetup will be Shannon Axelrod
from the Chan Zuckerberg initiative on
building software for biology research
into the cells and so that will be
Wednesday March 11th at 6 p.m. also here
so now it's time for our community
announcements so for the folks that are
new every month we have the opportunity
for the community to give announcements
so if you are hiring for somebody if
you're looking for a job if you're
hiring for a job if you have other
meetups or other events or really
anything that you think would be
relevant to the PI data community feel
free to stand up introduce yourself and
talk about it
very
the co-sponsors of the Ann Arbor power
users group heat up we're gonna have a
meeting tomorrow
as spark which is about two blocks away
I'll be giving the top and how you get
up and running with our studio on AWS it
won't be a deep talk in a Tobuscus I'm
just learning it'll be as deep as my
experience you right yes 6:30 Roxanne
6:30 gets part of the right foods and
we're looking for speakers so we've ever
learned that former chief anyone's got
something we want to give a talk on our
related topic
great anyone else and I think it's also
for family and friends what's happening
in AI and the next one will be March 13
you're next and that would be on
building conversation great and what's
your name
well welcome if anyone has any questions
I can talk to you after
see me afterwards what are you doing
sighs interest oh gosh how much time do
we have
I love anything unsupervised learning
very interested an LPS kind of stuff
super excited about it
so I've done a lot of projects and just
consider see what's out there
great thank you any other announcements
great all right so in this talk
Amy will walk through how to use the
text rank algorithm for summarization
and she'll demonstrate its application
with a real-world use case summarization
of news articles so Amy take it away hi
everyone I'm Amy hem etre I'm an
artificial intelligence engineer at
interactions here in Ann Arbor we're
located in Kerry town we work mainly we
work exclusively with NLP for our AI
group and we also mostly make chat BOTS
that we have some other products as well
so that's sort of why I'm here to talk
about an NLP topic how to do
summarization of news articles using
text rank and actually if you are
interested in NLP we have a meet up on
the 27th and that QR code will take you
to meet up comm where you can RSVP yes
right now so if you want to do that you
can while this QR code is up it's going
to be brian lester giving the talk my
colleague it's called your neural
network for NLP is probably wrong and
he's going to talk about some common
mistakes people make using deep learning
for NLP including padding which is why
we have that picture that's a real
picture from facebook some bad machine
translation and one of my plug groups so
that is on the 27th it's at spark which
as barry mentioned is just a couple
blocks away and that's another thing you
can check out if you're interested in
NLP
okay so this is another QR code for the
github repo for this talk so this repo
will include everything you need to
reproduce this talk it'll include a PDF
of these slides as well as the data that
we used the script I used to get the
data so you can change the source if you
want and get your own data you can
change the keyword I used and get your
own data you can play with it however
you want and then it also includes the
Jupiter notebook with the code that I
used for this talk so if you want that
grab it now and if not we will move on
okay so let's jump into the problem you
want to follow a keyword in the news and
you want to get updates about that
keyword just to clear up any confusion
right now this means like a search term
not keyword extraction which is another
kind of summarization so that's what I
mean when I say keyword here we're not
going to talk about keywords
summarization in this specific talk but
you can also use text text main for that
so you want to follow a keyword and you
want to get news updates about the
keyword you want to get 20 articles that
pop up but you don't want to read them
necessarily you just want to get a sense
for what's happening so how do you how
do you solve that problem you can use
summarization so our task is to get two
to three sentences from each article
that some of the content of this article
in our case we're actually going to use
two this is also called extractive
summarization there's also a type of
summarization called abstractive where
you can generate new sentences and
phrases but that's beyond the scope of
this talk so we're only going to talk
about extractive summarization of full
sentences not keyword summarization or
generating new sentences
so we want to get two to three sentences
how do we determine which of the
sentences are important we can use a
tool called text rank which you may have
defined from the title of this talk it's
a paper originally by Omaha Joe and
Tyrell in 2004 and we're gonna get into
all the details pretty soon it basically
does exactly what we want to do for our
task it ranks sentences so you can
choose the top end sentences for your
summary again we will be using two it
can also be used for keywords but we
won't be doing that today and it draws
its inspiration from Google's PageRank
algorithm which begs the question what
is PageRank and I apologize in advance
if you're familiar with PageRank this is
gonna feel a little bit like I'm beating
a dead horse but I want everyone to come
out of here knowing how PageRank and
text rank works so I'm gonna try to go
step by step so let's pretend you have
an Internet of three web pages right you
have links between those pages the first
is from here to here
and it also links from here to here so
that's one web page linking to two other
web pages and you have one more link
from the GRANDMONT on to the bottom of
one on the bottom left using these links
we can imagine ourselves as a
theoretical web surfer so you start with
the probability of being at each node
initialize to either some random value
or you can use a simple proportion of
the overall probability in this case it
would be one third for each webpage
because we had three web pages so the
algorithm for PageRank iterates through
and pretends to be this web surfer
clicking through and each time the web
surfer clicks through at random with the
new probabilities based on the update
that we'll talk about soon by the time
the algorithm converges and again we'll
get to this in a moment the web surfer
should end up here because this is the
page with the most most links to it
and this would be the second highest
ranked page this is the general idea
super simplified but we're getting into
a little bit more nitty-gritty once we
get to the page rank update formula so
we're just going to provide some
familiarity with the original formula so
we can make comparisons to Tex rank VI
is our target node and s VI is the score
for that node so this is the score that
determines how important the webpage is
in VI is the set of vertices that point
to VI in the graph VJ is the one of the
nodes in in VI since we're summing over
all of those nodes and that's the source
node for this this part of the update as
we sum through s VJ is the score so
we're also not only taking into account
the scores the edges of the other nodes
but also the scores of the other nodes
so a recommendation from a node with a
lower score is not worth as much as a
recommendation from a page of the higher
score and then this part represents the
number of edges going out of VJ so this
part normalizes for pages that have a
lot of links going out so if we have
these so-called link e pages we might we
want to weigh them as less important
then pages that only use a few links
because in theory the ones that only
provide a few links will only provide
links to the most important other pages
and then finally D is a damping factor
that can be set between 0 & 1 it
integrates the probability of jumping
from a given vertex to another random
vertex in the graph into the model so in
the context of web surfing it uses the
damping to create the random surfer
model so a user can click at random with
probability D and then they can jump to
a completely new page with probability 1
minus D this essentially allows the
surfer
to keep moving even if they reach a page
with no links so they can move to a
different page they don't get stuck it
also acts as a kind of smoothing so now
that we have seen the update formula
once we can move in with a little bit of
a more detailed sample graph and we can
go through and so you can really see so
let's pretend that this is a graph of
web pages with each letter being a web
page so we have the update formula on
the right here and D is our target node
so D is VI in this case in VI is all of
the nodes that point to D so all of the
red nodes in this graph these are the
nodes that were summing over to get the
score for D so let's say we're at the e
part of the summation abortion of the
page rank update so VJ in this case is e
if we look at this graph where the e
again we're at the e part of the
summation all of the ones that are
filled in now are out VJ so these are
the edges that are going out that we're
normalizing by so in this case this
number would actually just be three so
we would be multiplying the score of D
which is our VJ in this example by one
over three
do you just to be clear is not the
damping factor I'm talking about the
node I realize now that that's a little
bit confusing okay so now that we have a
little bit of knowledge of how PageRank
works we can go back to text rank it
also uses a graph representation where
the edges vote for the various vertices
but there are no links and sentences so
how do we use these sentences to
recommend other sentences we can use
similarity between the sentences so what
we end up with is not a directed
unweighted graph like we have with the
links we have a weighted undirected
graph and I'll show you how that works
minute this is the similarity metric
that we're gonna use it's the same one
that mahadji uses in her paper so we can
look at the numerator that's the number
of unique words that appear in both
sentences and those are divided and the
denominator by the sum of logs of the
number of unique words in each sentences
in NLP we refer to unique words as types
and individual words as tokens so you
can also say that these are the the logs
of the types in each sentence so the
denominator here normalizes for the
length of the sentences we don't want to
have a high similarity metric just
because a sentence has a lot of words
and then in it so we we use this to
normalize okay so here are some nonsense
sentences so we can take a look at how
this similarity metric looks so when we
plug them into the the formula we get
0.228 - for the first one because
there's one letter in common and that's
again normalizing for the length of the
sentences these sentences don't have any
words in common so the similarity metric
between these is going to be zero and
then finally these have two words in
common so this is the strongest
connection and it's the the highest
similarity so just like with the web
server example from PageRank we
initialize with equal scores and then we
iterate through as the text surfer
eventually pools around the same
sentences we stop iterating once we
converge and I again we're going to get
to that in a second but in this case
we'd end up with the top left sentence
as the highest ranking vertex the bottom
sentence as the second and the third is
the lowest rank sentence because there's
more weight going into the one in the
top so I've mentioned convergence a
couple of times what is convergence in
this context it's basically when the
error rate for any vertex falls below a
certain threshold in in the in the graph
so these are again the scores for each
node
and since this is an unsupervised task
we just calculate the error rate as the
difference between the scores and this
iteration in the last iteration so when
they start to get more similar than we
stopped and it's basically equivalent to
early stopping so let's get to how we
get these scores we use the text rank
update formula so note here that instead
of using asked for score we use WS for a
weighted score those are not two
different variables that just stands for
a weighted score and you'll see that
it's you see some similarities the first
is that again VI is our target notes so
just like before in the graph that we're
using which is very similar to the page
rank graph VI is our target note that
we're trying to get the score for and in
VI is the set of vertices that point to
VI again this shouldn't be looking
familiar VJ is one of the nodes of VI
that will be summing over and you can
see here we have a weighted score as
well and then here's the part that's the
different the most different this is the
sum of the weights for all edges that
are going out of VJ so instead of
counting the links we're summing up the
weights of the edges of VJ in the
context of PageRank this was to
normalize for the link e pages the ones
that had a lot of links and therefore we
didn't weigh their input as heavily as
the ones with fewer links so in this
case it's to lower the influences of
sentences that are really similar to
other sentences but are not good for
summarizing and it also acts as
smoothing and here again we use the same
damping factor you can see that the
whole algorithm is pretty similar to
PageRank with a few tweaks for being
appropriate for a weighted graph rather
than an unweighted graph and going back
to our example here if we went through
and did the scores we would end up with
something like this and you can see the
top sentence still wins
okay so now that we have some of the
basic concepts we can look at some code
and this is adapted from Brian Lester's
implementation of text rank and if you
follow that QR code there's a link to
this in my slides so
okay
all right Oh No
and I'm gonna just do ctrl C but my ctrl
key doesn't actually work on here so no
let me do this real quick
sorry about that
okay
okay so we'll start by importing the
packages we need and then we can take a
look at some of the sample data that I
got so if you want to see how I got this
data or if you want to make your own
data yes I'll see what I can do
that better thank you okay can you guys
see in the back okay great all right so
like I was saying you can if you want to
get this data or actually if you run my
script you'll probably get different
data because it's on a different day but
if you want to see the data you can go
to the github and I also have a script
that you can use to input your own
keywords or use your own preferred
sources through the news API okay so
here's an example of the the data we
have it's just a list of sentences
pretty simple this is an article about a
volcano and I just used the keyword
science because I figured it would be
kind of neutral though I think some of
these I would not classify them as side
science articles but that's okay okay so
let's get into the Python so this
function calculates the similarity
metric that we discussed before just the
the overlapping sets of the two
sentences normalized by their lengths
this function normalizes a token by
lower casing it and removing non
alphanumeric characters this one
basically uses that one we just ran on
every token in a sentence and then
rejoins them this one builds a vocab Mac
mapping tokens to indices so this
order's the nodes of the graph and the
index corresponds to where it first
appeared in the tokens list
okay now we can create the graph first
we're going to create a vertex object
and the vertex object has properties
relating to the update formula so if
you'll note we have a couple functions
within here the edges out and the edges
in those are related to our the formula
that we talked about this makes our
calculations more efficient and you'll
see that it runs very quickly when we
get to the actual running part okay and
then we create a graph object here using
the vertex class that we just created
I'm not going to go through all of the
details if you want to look at it this
later you're absolutely welcome to it's
all on github also my scrolling is not
super fast right now for some reason
okay so you can use a number of
different types of graphs with text rank
it's very flexible but for our example
we're be going to be using an adjacency
list that inherits the graph function
above so again just a reminder that the
vertices are the sentences in our data
and the edge weights are from the
similarity metric above so now we can
get into the actual text rank parts this
function calculates the total weight for
a collection of edges in the graph so if
you'll recall from before when I close
the window
that's the normalizing for the
originally for the linky pages and now
for the the large number of edge weights
or not number large proportion of edge
weights
this function accumulates the scores
from all nodes that have incoming
connections to a given node so this is
the summing over the NBI that we talked
about and then this function sort of
initializes the outgoing strength for
the adjacency lift graph this graph so
in this case we're going to initialize
the weights with a uniform distribution
just how we use 1/3 1/3 1/3 for the toy
example and it doesn't really matter
that we do this first because the sum of
the weights for outbound edge is for a
given node don't change
we're only updating the scores as we go
so we can compute this first and we use
it and you can see this is the WS and
denominator that it returns and then we
use the double that information here and
then this should look familiar because
this is again our text rank formula here
so this is the update formula
this function outputs the text rank
scores for each of the vertices in the
graph and then this function actually
runs text rank so this is where we put
in all the good stuff like the damping
the convergence the convergence type so
I said before we we converge when we get
to a certain threshold for any of the
nodes and overt vertex but you can also
do it for all of the nodes in a vertex
there's almost other neat features that
I won't really get into right now but so
this is just where you put in all that
information and then stepping back to
our specific data this function will
create the graph out of our specific
sentences
and finally we have a summarised
function that will return the summaries
for articles so this is the good stuff
okay so that was all of this
inflammation implementation of text
ranked we're going to run it on our data
now
and I'm gonna get back to my slides real
quick
so so
one more change of this
thank you for being with me I know this
is like a little painful okay so I just
wanted to look at the output of some of
the summaries just to show you how this
this thing really works and I don't know
if you can all see that I'll just read
it out loud in case some people at the
back are having trouble seeing it says
Volkswagen is partnering with the
University of Tennessee and the Oak
Ridge National Laboratory to create the
company's first innovation hub for
developing new technology in North
America official said Friday in a
statement working with the University of
Tennessee and Oak Ridge National
Laboratory is a great opportunity to
continue growing Volkswagens engineering
footprint in the North American region
said Wolfgang dem abara Abner vwz SEC
executive vice president and chief
engineering officer for the region so
how do we feel pretty good right I feel
like we have a pretty good sense for
what happened to that article and I
haven't read the rest of the article but
I don't feel like I need necessarily
have to so I mean this is just a good
example I can show you one more one more
example that I thought was pretty good
actually there were I I'm not like
cherry-picking here they were mostly
pretty good so this one says schools and
businesses shed across the Philippine
capital on Monday as a volcano belched
clouds of ash across the city in
seismologists warned that an eruption
could happen at any time potentially
triggering a tsunami thousands of people
were forced to evacuate their homes
around tall one of the world's smallest
active volcanoes which spewed ash for a
second day from its crater in the middle
of a lake about 70 kilometers south of
central Manila so again I think we have
a pretty good idea of what happened we
have a lot of the five W's you talk
about in journalism who what where when
how I don't know how is it W
I don't remember what the five W's are
but it is we're okay yeah the point is
we have a lot of information here I
think it's I think it's pretty good so
you can see that for a fairly simple
algorithm and you don't have to use GPUs
or anything it runs really fast you get
a very good quality summary in the
interest of fairness I chose a bad one
but this was not typical at all so I'll
just read it all out again in every
country we have a business presence
we're committed to complying with the
applicable laws and regulations and
Canada is no different how it said
regardless of the decision our position
is we will continue to serve our
customers in Canada with our products
and networks I don't know what's going
on in that article I'm not sure why
they're bragging about following laws I
don't know what the products are all I
know is Canada so I guess this one was
not such a good summary but I actually
had to dig for this one so I think that
actually says mostly good things about
text right because this was really the
only one where I was I really had no
idea what was going on yeah it could be
that the article wasn't good we always
have other people to blame just too I
was actually kind of hoping there would
be more of these because I tried to do
it in three different sources with the
word science but it turns out there's a
lot of science happening in the world
but these are two articles about the
same story and they are actually both
from Reuters they were just in different
places so one was in to a place in
Manila and one took place in Tagaytay
City which is where the actual volcano
is and I I guess I'll read these allowed
to because the the text is a little bit
smaller we actually read the first one
earlier so I don't have to read that one
but the second one says we prayed that
we can rise up put a stop to this
calamity and allow us to return back to
our homes said forty-four-year-old
evacuate any via nova a lot of families
like us want to be together in our homes
and stand up more than 70 thousand
people have been evacuated since the
tall one of the Philippines most active
volcanoes begin spewing clouds of ash
steam and gas On January 12 so we get
some of the same information between
these two stories and again these are
texts Frank is running only on one story
at a time so it's not like it combines
these we just wanted to see how the
algorithm would hold up between two and
you can see some of the same information
they both mention the name of the
volcano they both use the phrase spewing
ash so that's kind of interesting and
you basically there's a little bit more
of a personal angle to the second one
but that's I think says more about the
way the article was written than it does
about the algorithm so but I think since
they come contain some of the same
information that's pretty good I think
this is good things about text Frank as
well some other details that I thought
would be interesting to throw in here so
33% of the summaries contain the first
sentence and you can kind of see that
here right so like Manila Reuters
I saved I left that in there just so you
can still see it but 33% of the
summaries did contain the first sentence
and in fact that's actually an accepted
pretty strong baseline in summarization
it's if you have if you just summarize
with the first sentence of an article in
news articles specifically that's called
lead one if you have to its lead to if
you have three is slayed three so I
think that's that's kind of interesting
that 33% of the time text rank honed in
on that yes
what is Isis
i I don't know what do you think Brad
whereas person did you talk about
without some experiment and pointing the
other way all make sense because the SS
would be too early so that's a little
bit of knowing your data how to send the
data
oh I'm so sorry
so for news articles it makes sense to
point towards the first sentence because
you that's where you get most of the
information but it depends on the data
so in movie reviews you tend to have
more of the summary happening at the end
so it depends on your data it's a matter
of knowing your data did you also hear
the question yeah yeah
a reverse sentence or a reverse like
order of sentences so for the words in
the sentence it should be the same
similarity metric because it's a set of
unique words overlapped so it doesn't
take order into account the similarity
metric if you are reverse the order of
the sentences it does make a difference
they just picked the last sentence
the summarization algorithm because
that's where all come or not
it seems like that's how it's written
pretty much summarized
[Music]
so you talk primarily about the
undirected version where it really
assumes that you have if you think of
the patron graph you have edges going
both ways right so you have two centers
you connect them and you work with them
as if they were edges going both ways
but then you can also think of directed
graphs and then you can add direction
depending on like I said on the data so
for news articles for instance you could
given two sentences you could you would
still have the similarity which is what
you talked about but then the direction
of the edge would go from towards the
beginning of the text right so say
sentence three and sentence one it would
go from three to one because one
happened earlier or you could also have
it the other way around right so going
toward the end of the document and that
would make sense like I said for movie
reviews or other types of documents
where the essence of the text tends to
happen toward the end as opposed to
toward at the beginning questions for
Radha
[Laughter]
that's a Michigan difference okay I have
just a couple a couple more things and
then we can we can talk some more if we
want so basically any but this is an
accepted baseline called lead one and
it's interesting that 33 percent of
century the summaries contain the first
sentence I think lead one would have
made a really boring pi day to talk
which is why I didn't do it but and 17%
of the summaries contain the first
sentence as the highest-ranked sentences
so actually quite a few of them even if
they contain the first sentence decided
to rank another sons higher in in the
code we there's a if you run it yourself
there's a variable called keep order
so that will maintain your your
sentences in your summary in the order
they were in the article originally and
you don't have to do that but that's
that is something I kept for these
summaries so these might actually be in
different orders if we didn't run keep
order but I decided to run keep order
okay something else I was kind of
interested in was about the summary
lengths so only two of 20 of 58
summaries had an average summary
sentence length shorter than the average
sentence length for the data they were
in so we do get a I guess we get a
little bit of an effective length but to
be honest I think it was okay because
the summaries we got were pretty good I
think sometimes just the longest
sentence is the best summary so not
really sure what else to say about that
but overall I think that the summaries
were were pretty good quality and
surprisingly coherent coherent for a
fairly simple algorithm that just
extract sentences and I think it's a
really good option for something fairly
simple and very quick and that's all I
have questions
[Applause]
and then when you were looking at the
outputs we were saying like this looks
good or this like seems good so if you
were to compare this this model to like
leave two models within two sentences
how could you do that like or is there a
way to do that like in a fairly
objective way to see like you know how
much better is this that'll lead to
baseline
there are evaluation metrics I didn't
really write much down about them I
think they're in the paper though I can
pull it up maybe yeah so it's people we
summarize the documents and then you
would compare
say the leads to against those summaries
and then carpet or another civilization
put against those references
and you can do that the number of ways I
think the more while the use ones are
when you look at sentence level really
looking at the human reference which are
the sentences that they selected verses
which are the ones that say you are
aware of selective weather is going to
work another one and then the results
and that works also for babies she was
supervisor well you need a crafter you
could compare them but then it doesn't
tell you anything other than whether
they are similar to one another or not
but it's not
respectable what they will see okay I
can't remember if you touched on it in
your intro but is there a sensible way
to maybe combine pay drink and Tech's
rank to sort of get even richer
summaries maybe across different outlets
that might have different points of view
or something I'm not sure how I'd
combine PageRank and text right because
they're already pretty combined unless
you mean like can you expand on that a
little so say you have five articles
about the same and you don't want you
want a summary of of that thing from all
of those articles hmm how can you sort
of combine the text rank within each and
the page rank between
all right look you have a Google search
and then you choose the best page and
then you do text rank on that and get
the summary yeah you can do that I don't
see why not
no I'm just because of the equation it
seems
you know each sentence that was
connected to
yeah I mean I imagine you would
eventually be limited by computational
fat power but I think it's so fast right
now that it would have to be some books
and there is much better if you are up
on a challenge try some books and see
how it doesn't work that long it's also
because there is a lot of topic changes
is not back in a news article you just
have one topic in turnout and so the way
we've done it is to parse the topic
segmentation and then do summarization
and then tries for money but it still
when you look at the summary of verse a
400-page book it's okay for this month
as
great this their weapons and that would
be whoever wants to try that but left
you how all those dimensionality
reduction yes senator they're close
enough where you just combined them and
at what you can reduce the number of
things I don't care how well does that
work with that wait a CA or something
like that out we haven't really tried
that particular way so in fact other
ways of fighting the size of the problem
you know segmentation was one thing like
try to cut the text into smaller pieces
but it still doesn't work as well as
let's talk about that just any other
other questions Amy
I guess my question is are there other
applications other than like summarizing
news articles you've come across or you
can think of one came to my mind was VP
find out what the neuters newest hashtag
on Twitter is about baby get a good
summary or at the top five most related
tweets I don't know do you have any
other ideas um I don't know about that I
mean I guess if you I don't know if I
would use it on tweets cuz they're so
short anyway and it's like it's not like
a news article where they were they
would all be connected I mean I guess
you could maybe use it I don't know what
the results would be like tweet would be
one sentence and then you basically want
to say like what does firstworldproblems
being and so you find a whole bunch of
tweets that a representative or have
that hashtag mmm there are other
applications
I could actually answer that question
would you beat up Kayla and I said oh
this text I'm working on learning NLP by
analyzing certain comments then when
you're talk to him up said what is text
Frank it's it sounds cool grab some
sample code and rent under survey
comments which are generally short the
results are nonsensical because it's
looking for a sentence and very
ungrammatical short snippets I didn't
know what the method is really doing so
I just throw it in your brush out
right so in this update formula we have
the normalization so that's clearly
gonna take care of like sentences that
are very similar to stuff because it
really bland
but it seems like what this is going to
do is kind of select out sentences that
are very similar to each other
did you notice like similar not
somewhere to everything but just to
another
have you noticed like problems with like
diversity and since like are all this
innocent summary like pretty say me like
Jersey sentence really add that much
information a good question we can look
at some if you want I thought they were
mostly just very summarize II not so
sent I mean like some of them are just
really long so I mean I think that the
one that I actually showed as a bad
example was a very bland Sami sense like
there's nothing going on here except
maybe a lot of the other ones have
customer and regulations and business
and all these so this was I'm sorry I
thought I was on the mirror one hold on
a second
this one I think this is a good example
of maybe where that where that could
have happened
wait don't get very much we have a five
ways to find ways to so if those
services are too similar to one another
we'll actually get them out of the Sun
did we all hear that no okay so in some
longer documents where there's a little
bit more repetition and redundancy text
ranks sometimes pulls out things that
are similar to one another but don't
necessarily summarize the document well
because there's so much repetition and
it doesn't necessarily work as well as
the news articles that are a little bit
more concise so they've had to use other
methods to deal with that okay that is
also the case if you do multiple
documents and run the algorithm on
multiple documents instead of one at a
time so I know I learned a lot about
text Frank and I also learned a bit of
backstory from Radha as well which is
back in 2004 it was published right that
uh it took about a week to write the
code in tests and another week to write
the paper and the next thing you know
with longevity of the work there were
the 3,000 citation plus citation is
right so we can all aspire to being that
not only efficient but producing worth
that I have that sort of lasted a test
of time but with that let's take Amy for
another great talk
[Applause]